good morning John I recently realized
that I have an obsession I didn't know
about which is not that unusual for me I
was just scrolling through my photos
like you do and I noticed that in the
last few weeks I've taken a lot of
pictures of signs so then I just
searched Google photos for signs and I
found out that I have taken like
hundreds of pictures of signs over the
last 15 years the earliest one was
actually from 2004 so we're we're
getting up close to 20. and a lot of
them are just objectively very good so
I'm going to share with you now my
favorites one thing I love about a sign
is if it's telling me more than it
thinks it's telling me for example this
Swan Hunters must have visible means of
retrieval sign told me that there are
Swan hunters in the world and that
sometimes they shoot a swan that they
cannot retrieve and that that is a
problem that can only really be avoided
in one way this sign told me that pit
toilets are cleaned by human beings
which is something I probably should
have known but didn't it also just has a
tremendous Kick-Ass aesthetic with all
of the scratch graffiti this sign told
me that somebody kicked the pony I also
really like secret signs like this one I
found on the inside door of a mailbox I
also like signs that tell me there's a
story without telling me what the story
is like these three signs that all say
do not enter but one of them has been
taped over like why why tape over one
there is a story here I cannot imagine
what it is I love a beautiful sign but I
also love a sign that becomes more
beautiful like this Railway marker the
way that the coding on the sign fractal
differently given the different shape of
the W and the five same with these two
danger signs so great and this rusted up
Beast was at that same power station
which was behind the lab I worked at in
2004. these were the oldest photos I
have of signs possibly this was the
beginning of my obsession oh so long ago
aging signs is something I really seem
to be into I looked at this one for a
really long time but I could never
figure out what the danger was and then
there's the sign marker at the end of a
trail in the National Bison Range that I
have taken pictures of so many times
that I have a catalog of its
deterioration I love signs that try to
be very clear and succeed like this
danger sign I saw in Italy but I also
love signs that try too hard to be very
clear like this no e-bike sign that has
one two three four different indicate
caters that it's talking specifically
about e-bikes very clearly every person
in the meeting had a different idea for
how to represent e-bikes and they
decided to use all of them but most of
all my favorite genre of sign it's clear
and looking through them is signs that
are accidentally funny but before we get
to that I gotta remind you that you are
going to need to buy socks throughout
your life but instead of that being a
chore I want to take care of it for you
the awesome socks Club will send you a
pair of socks designed by a different
independent artist every month we've
worked hard to make them cozy and
durable and delightful shipping is free
you can cancel anytime and all the
profit goes to decrease maternal and
child mortality in Sierra Leone you can
sign up for ankle socks or mid-calf
cruise and you can get five dollars off
your first month with a link in the
description you can pause the video
right now I will still be here when you
get back so what do I mean by
unintentionally funny designs well there
is a Hall of Fame example here in
Missoula Montana this sign which is
meant to be two signs but it is
impossible to not read it as one certain
misspelled signs can be very funny for
example this yard sale sign was a huge
win for me once I really hit the jackpot
when they were reorganizing my grocery
store got snack time Eye Care and
feminine care breakfast juices and Candy
as well as baby care bleach dish soap
this one I can't really tell if it was
meant to be funny it seemed entirely
sincere so I'm including it then there's
this giant bronze banana in Palm Springs
one of the hottest places in America and
it's hot it's a hot banana it's a hot
banana it's on the edge of whether this
is a sign but these labeled poster boxes
from the dftba warehouse which can
either be red top to bottom or bottom to
top giving very different perspectives
on the human story and then I'm gonna
end with one of my faves is it my
favorite I don't know maybe maybe it is
but please don't flash the octopus it's
it's in it's at least in the top tier
John you can only sign up for the
awesome Sox Club this week and next week
so you might as well go do it now I'll
see you on Tuesday
oh look and as a special present this is
wild I had 15 extra seconds in this
video even though the script was very
long so I I don't know what I did I
guess I talked really fast but here's
some others of my favorites okay five
dollars off the awesome socks club with
the link in the description